sugar Corey that's the fight that's the
most entertaining fight if you're a
purist you want Corey versus Moran I
think the UFC is a new Corey versus
sugar it's more fun I still think sugar
would be an underdog in that fight it's
a winnable fight for Suga there's no
easy fights for sugar anymore that's not
happening pigeon was not an easy fight
he passed that test thank God shout out
to Corey Sandhill that's what kind of
savage he is for calling um Rob out the
rest of the division is like uh-uh so
morab Corey said hey you makes sense but
if I'm the UFC uh I just have him Rob
wait for the title shot morob's gonna be
chilling for a little bit because I bet
they do Cory versus sugar that's the
fight